as the me2 movement works to give women
and girls a greater voice it is also
bringing new attention to how boys are
raised and the pressures they face
according to research 30 percent of high
school boys say they have been in a
fight the latest data also shows boys
are more likely to take their own lives
than girls in his book how to raise a
boy the power of connection to build
good men psychologist Michael Reichert
says quote there is a real opportunity
today to get boyhood right perhaps for
the first time Michael joins us first
here on CBS this morning welcome that to
be with you all thank you for having me
what are what are we doing wrong with
the way we're raising boys I think that
just the basic understanding of boys
natures is off base I think we don't
really perceive them as relational and
emotional creatures but what we know is
that you know our human brains are wired
to connect and our emotions are a
critical part of how we relate to the
world how we understand ourselves so
getting that right is fundamentally
important I think for building good men
right you talk about nourishing
essentially that part of that what is
the man box that you describe yeah great
question it's a set of cultural norms
that I think have been around forever I
think that the idea of conditioning boys
to fit into a certain role is heavily
prescriptive and it actually cuts boys
men off from our human nature's
particularly our relationships so what
are some of those norms for people who
are strong be tough be willing to fight
man yeah man up don't show Joe upset
right the grill that kind of stuff how
is the me2 moving and changing the way
we raised it dramatically I think that
actually I think the women's movement in
general has opened up the possibilities
for us to consider reconsider manhood
and masculinity in a positive way you're
saying in a very positive way things are
dramatically different for this
generation of boys your son then then my
sons are certainly me I think there's a
whole new understanding of how to get
along with people
how to hold on to our hearts that's
happening for boys now you say that
there is often a gap between what a boy
feels and what those close to him know
so what are we supposed to do with that
because you're looking at your son and
you're thinking he seems okay but really
there's a lot going on inside that we
don't know yeah
George Orwell the British writer had
this wonderful quote he wears a mask and
he grows to fit it yeah yeah and I think
that you know in addition to the man box
there's this idea of the mask of
masculinity that boys have to hide
behind or they're vulnerable to being
badly treated
boys are told don't show that you're
nervous are scared even when you are for
sure and you're told that you said by
your parents and we have to learn how to
be strong and stoic by three years old
Mike Mike two and half year old grandson
is learning that now and even in
situations where you have to be strong
and stoic I mean there are some moments
emotionally whether you're a man or a
woman where strength helps with a
partner or a family member you still
need to have the ability to talk about
so how do you get young boys to talk
about these complicated emotional issues
which people you know all kinds of
different people have trouble with I
have the luxury of working at a boy
school that side of Philadelphia and I
lead a emotional literacy program for
about 40 or 50 boys that show up
voluntarily
that's so cool you actually call it the
best program in the school they come and
I help them talk to each other about
difficult emotional topics they have no
trouble doing it yeah if we build it
they will come no you said if you
provide a safe place that's right where
they feel that they're being listened to
and that people really want to hear it
they will open up amazing things happen
when they speak yeah what what we see is
that there you know what we know from
research is it's not the experience of
emotions that different between men and
women boys and girls it's the expression
hmm and the expression follows feeling
rules that we culturally prescribed and
Michael do we need as parents of boys to
think about these conversations is
happening maybe not between fathers and
sons or mothers and sons but between a
young man and someone like you all right
coach sharing right or great I know the
boys that I see the young men that I see
love talking to each other but there's a
role that I play as an
man we are the keepers of boyhood where
that we're the architects and the
managers of boyhood we have to give
permission you write also about special
time and how important it is for parents
to have that with their sons I know
everybody homes like give me some
lessons give me something to hold on to
that I could talk about that special
time yeah it's basically the idea that
that that if we can put aside we come to
parenting generally parenting boys in
particular with lots of anxiety and
worries if we are concerns or desires
that kind of manage them in a particular
way if we can put all that aside and get
with our sons and simply follow their
lead indicating to them that we love
being with them they're delighted
they're delightful to us and we're
willing to go where they go whatever it
might be without modifying things
mm-hmm that's a fundamental skill in
building a relationship and
strengthening a connection yeah yeah you
just be in each other's presence well
and for the boy to get the message that
I'm gonna pay attention to you and be
with you regardless I like what you said
it men aren't the only ones that can
raise really good boys and really good
men you know mothers and women in all I
play a very key role yeah yeah the Mamas
that way myth yeah pervades and and
makes unfortunately many women feel like
they need to let their sons go at the
risk of ruining their masculinity and
it's actually just the opposite yes stay
close keeping them close yeah I believe
that thank you Michael nice talking with
you all thanks for having this man how
to raise a boys on sale today wherever
you like to buy your books